they are expecting me happily go skip
respect three in one of the most unusual
apartments I have ever seen
first a hallway long and dark then 16
rooms with 16 families this is a common
alga a shared apartment a relic from
Soviet times traveling back in history
traveling back to the USSR at least
that's what it looks like here in the
heart of st. Petersburg I meet people
who have made a home in the common ELCA
home they value despite all the
difficulties after the power lines from
the 50s can be a problem
it's actually awful here
the kitchen is the heart of the
communica with clear rules and a strict
hierarchy good for those who have lived
here longer get the better parts that
means your own table and your own part
of the communal stove I was born here so
my husband and I are among the
privileged ones science common alcazar
an integral part of life in San
Petersburg the hell people feel as alone
in the big city the shabby but also cozy
communal apartments are a stark contrast
to the opulent tourist attractions and
they are also right in the center in the
old town a privilege I visit one of
these privileged residents in Rome
number three
Martha Polina and her daughter Alexandra
played music
which seems to make yo chic the cat's
hungry father you've gained you wants to
install a heating and cooling system for
the winter little Alexandre shouldn't
have to freeze while the heater breaks
down again as it often does right here
premium Russian now is like the Soviet
Union in the 70s the economy will
ultimately collapse and a new life will
begin but we won't live to see that
which is why we don't have big plans for
the future you spending Michonne on
shows week there's no reason we can't be
happy in this country want to put it
another way
there's nothing here we hate so much
that we'd have to leave because Russia
has flaws but what country doesn't live
from her knees a shortage of food is
something this country definitely
doesn't have I stopped at a market to
buy groceries for a communal cameo
merchants at scenery knock sell their
products at Western prices like in the
stores but with average monthly income
in Russia the equivalent of just 400
euros shopping here is very expensive
this orig section of foodstuffs
shouldn't hide the fact that more and
more Russians can hardly pay for this in
times of crisis i buy mutton as
requested by a nose bag family in the
common Alka who wants to make cloth a
rice dish just passing by first evil
dobra by civil study back in the commune
Elka the boundaries between public and
private realms disappear as even ink
approaches especially with a smell of
roasting mutton the Uzbek Applebee's
earned his wife whose name they want to
divulge would rather not talk about
Russia where their guests are cast this
woosh we just earned that money here
that's more than we do in Uzbekistan
there is a mini Uzbekistan here of
kitchen with rice and carrots and lots
of
a piece of salons beg is done in the
Russian north for yevgeniy and Paulina
there is chocolate and chips tonight but
also lots of common Alka philosophy and
talk about the Duma elections I have no
idea when I voted the last time when was
it sherry Gooley sure the early 2000s
who are we even supposed to vote for we
don't have a real opposition with its
own platform that would promise us a
better life for you but for a country as
big as Russia needs imperialist style
leadership with a totalitarian touch
anyone who wants to change that would
have to risk instability I don't want
that many Russians accepted this
imperialist style of leadership with a
totalitarian touch a promise of
stability is how President Vladimir
Putin guarantees the support of so many
in Russia but for how long the current
economic crisis makes a stable future
work increasingly like an illusion
you